[Music]
joy diamond such movies is sex Lies and
videotape the player while you were
sleeping American beauty and on
television with the OSI California
Californication Grayson Frankie and now
the new NBC show that's on Sunday nights
at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central Zoe's
extraordinary playlist starring our next
guest Peter Gallagher good to see you
sir you got it you got it so you're from
New York City caresse sir do you still
have that accent a little bit you know I
have a little my mom was she she was
pretty well raised in the Bronx yes so I
still have a little of my ear I had I
could hear it a little bit when I
started doing sports casting I used to
say NC double-a tournament
you know and then it's like tournament
and you know New York and stuff like
that and then I had a start saying ok
tournament like literally spell out the
word tu RN and spell it out why when I'm
doing SVU yes and I'm like half the guys
are from the Bronx or you know the from
there my era New York and that kind of
yeah dialed that vibe that's
disappearing fast
I just and the plus the character I
played there chief Dodds yeah Franklin
New Yorker from it sounds like now it
sounds like you sound more like a New
York but if you cut me off in traffic it
was like my wife is from Boston watching
her oh oh my god you watch she's
watching the Patriots or the Red Sox it
sounds if you're not in the room you'd
sound like somebody's getting killed and
my kids and I like she's converted all
of us because we're just watching her
watch watch the sports well like the
best entertainment ever my wife's a
die-hard Patriot fan from the womb Oh
get out yes as his crest across the way
right over there and I'm a die-hard jet
fan from the womb and I could not in my
own right rightful way with the Patriots
winning as many championships with Tom
Brady as they would been doing since my
children who had born I would think
child services would remove them from
house if I said no you must root for the
Jets instead of Tom Brady and the New
England Patriots right now you know
that's just the way it's been going in
my house what's interesting so you
married Boston and yes we met first week
of freshman year in college she was huge
she's she wears the sports pants in our
family okay okay
I do musicals you do including your
current show I'm not when I'm not
catatonic I'm singing a dance
exactly which pretty much we'll hit that
in a second done Zoey's extraordinary
playlist with Peter Gallagher here in
the Rich Eisen show so did you play
sports at all as a kid did you have oh
yeah you tried played briefly soccer and
we we lost every single game and not
only did we lose every single game we
never scored once winning all cuz we
were young okay if it was a young young
JV team and so I played for a year and I
had no skill but I had no regard for my
personal safety okay so I would just
send me in to just create havoc right
and then then I discovered the theater
and that was all and that was all she
wrote and then I played I played a
little hockey growing up you know just
pick up if it was no equipment if you
were if ten guys showed up would be five
if money would be tentative two would be
one of what if he cop hockey huh you
know just on the SLU's of Armonk New
York there's pond hockey yeah right and
in fact years later
Denis Leary called me up mm-hmm when my
son was playing hockey with against
Gretzky's kids come on wait yes hold on
a second your son is playing him against
Gretzky's because they were little boys
and he was playing him with a rein for
the Rangers then we would go to Chelsea
pier for our 6:00 a.m. practices in my
son was a goalie and and I remember one
day Wayne we were we would practice and
Wayne was there and he was like looking
so what's the matter my sons in the net
playing defense so chief Wayne take it
easy
don't like it woke up and decide hey I
want to design dresses which would be
fine but for him it was like the it's
like this like it was funny yeah I mean
if you're gonna put a big stick
oh my god Ben the foot so like a while
later denis leary called me up Shh stop
talking are we still on here tell me
that it's Larry's story mangoes Lawrence
calls me up he says Pete Wayne wants to
know if you want to play Friday so play
what because we've been talking about
golf hockey
I said you out of your mind I haven't
played hockey in 25 years and I I don't
have any equipments again but we'll get
your son two hours with with the Ranger
greats at the gardens yeah
you know on the ISIS oh I'm in so I
couldn't sleep about that night I wake
up an hour later in a cold sweat man
what's the matter sis
thinking to be bringing me home in a
body bag tomorrow and so I go I mean
while the other hockey dads are up there
going east the bravest man in the world
but I go to the locker room and I'm
Rhonda Gay and Cam Neely I said I had
never worn equipment yeah as a hockey
player and I'd never play it on a rink
ice so I said guys what's this does he
feel your legs okay okay great great
great great and anyway I skated my I
skated my shift so I almost had an
assist 13,000 people but the best thing
was I got home after practice the next
morning with my son and my wife said you
know that stationery that ranger station
area gave your son Dave gave Jamie hmm
said yeah well he started writing in it
for him to write in anything in that age
would have been less surprising me
flapped his arms and flew to the moon
right and said January 9th 1999 today
was the best day of my life that's the
best thing I couldn't walk for two weeks
and it was the best thing I that's
exactly right Peter Gallagher here on
the Rich Eisen show and so that's at
Madison Square Garden addison square
garden at one point said Gallagher and I
heard my name is Owen done something
wrong and I say now your name's up in
the rafters there right yeah Peter
Gallagher here on the Rich Eisen show
and you
I saw you rolling some putts right there
you played in the AT&T Pebble Beach
correct I did I played a few times and I
played because of Jack Lemmon okay Jack
Lemmon gave me my first set of golf
clubs when he was doing long day's
journey and tonight okay and he was
always talking about you know I got to
play the AT&T he gave you get me perfect
hmm and I had the remarkable experience
of playing the 80
mmm-hmm should I tell the story we
should I don't know I don't know what
you give it up radio with the thing just
we're just here to having a conversation
it's all good
so uh so I'm teeing off with Dan poll
question I've gotten in the eighteen t
cuz I was doing a movie with Bill Murray
in London okay you'll go to the driving
range and hit nice at the end he says
hey you want to play some golf and
January pebble said man I would love to
believe Philly it's like the AT&T I'm
not good enough to play in that I know
and but if Bill Murray is on the field
Kappa Dan and I had no I remember the
night before the things started I was
gonna hope my hotel room thinking how
does this pudding thing work right you
know and but on the 8th 18th hole of
pebble was our third round we tee off
Dan pole pole cat and I and he says you
know we're gonna make the cut mm-hm we
were 22 under part we're gonna because
every time he said I need a par at of
you and I need a par at you now and I
remember over sip my hands would be
shaking but somehow if I made a bogey it
would be a net par if I made a par it
would be a nut birdies I mean we were 22
under please and I'm thinking holy God I
can't I can't make the cut that's gonna
kill lemon and I said no he's gonna be
so proud of me
yeah and so we're we're hitting up to
the 18th green and there's lemon and Dan
Oh Dave Pelz this was his caddie that
year cuz it's Jack I mean you're gonna
make the cut this year I'm gonna work
with you a full year I'm gonna be on
your bag we're gonna do it yeah so Jack
is waiting with Pels behind the 18th
green Jack is like this and Dave Pelz is
like that and go he's gonna be so proud
of me working we're coming up to the
green and he I waved the jack and he
goes you're gonna make the cut you we
missed it by one and I was almost
relieved like a father
based on what you're tell me Peter
Gallagher here on the Rich Eisen show
you're a young man
who chose the theater over sports and
yet skated with Gretzky and Cam Neely
and the Rangers greats in Madison Square
Garden and almost made the cut at the
AT&T at Pebble Beach it's it's me my god
Peter it is that's the crazy your
beginner in every single aspect you
might want it you know oh shoot a little
lower before you go for them you know
that's the crazy thing about being an
actor it's like marchello monster yata
called it a luxury tourist we get to do
things we should not be allowed to do
with people that we should not be
allowed to be doing them with it's part
of these if you have no qualms about
jumping into an experience you're not
qualified for right it could just lead
you to them
you know remarkable remarkable thing
it's funny that we talked about it back
Chris I don't know if you're aware of a
Peter Gallagher and I share one thing in
common we know we've both been put in
films by the director Jon Turteltaub who
had him and while you were sleeping and
he gave me my first break in Disney's
the kid the kid playing myself I was
awake peter was mostly asleep in his
that's art that's basic and we're both
from New York City that's our connection
and jon turteltaub were directed two
episodes of Zoe this is always and I
don't speak in that easy so at least
with rich he doesn't mind his new time
sing with me says I'll do it as long as
Gallagher keeps his mouth shut
it's working for both of us my gosh
so Zoe's extraordinary playlist you play
a dad with a rare neurological disease
and your daughter can hear what you're
thinking through music this is the
episode three that's coming up on this
new series of premiered in January
episode 2 aired this past Sunday I'm
wondering what what you love about this
show theatre you know what I love about
this show it's the same thing I loved
about the OC The OC was like a great
show to be telling right on the heels
and 9/11 when people were starting to
get worried about strangers and
foreigners and feelings and a phobic and
Sandy Cohen shows up says I'm not scared
mmm I'm not scared of people being
different come on into my house we'll
take it that to me was an American
unafraid response that to me was more
ameri-ghen and saying keep those people
out keep these people out and this show
is all about the things that connect us
and we're in such a divided time I
thought it would be so powerful to be
telling a story that suggests that
everybody has a story and you don't know
what it is unless you listen and it
doesn't matter what they look like or
where they come from you will be
surprised and you will be surprised
about how much we all share and these
songs that all release hit songs that we
do already reside in us mhm and and and
it's kind of what connects us when we
discover that we feel the same way about
being recognized or family or loss or
love or you know you know when in
theater when you do your job really well
and you're on stage and it's something
like that and it and there's a moment
and it works for a moment no one in that
room feels alone no one in that everyone
for a moment feels like we're all
members of the same tribe and this show
I'm hoping will inspire those same
feelings if the connection we have to
each other you know that that there's a
lot more the connexxus than divides us
so that's really and also my mother had
Alzheimer's for 20 years and and it's
not a dissimilar disease to PSP which is
more parkinsonian but just that and my
dad didn't really talk to me much
growing up you know he was in World War
two in the Battle of the Bulge and his
mom died young his dad was a coal miner
and I mean we would watch Notre Dame
football because miraculously he and his
working brothers got to Notre Dame and
we'd go to Mass but there was about the
same amount of dialogue during both of
those experiences so I always looked at
my dad and I wondered what was going on
when he was that far away look in his
eye and so it's about feeling connected
the people you you can't seem to reach
to know beautifully put Peter really and
it's a beautiful show 9:00 Eastern 8:00
central on NBC on on Sunday nights
before I let you go my wife would kill
me if I didn't ask you a question about
why you were sleeping is that it is that
the film that you get them
most about what do you get the most well
that's that you know them while you were
sleeping is up there the OSI is up there
and the idolmaker
oddly my first movie is people of must
be playing somewhere or something and
unfortunately it's a lot of different
things but while you were sleeping as it
is a big one glad to see you woke up
yeah right it's all good and you know
plus we had such a great cast Peter
Boyle Jack Ward and Glynis John's yeah
well and I got to be friends on that oh
is that right and you know that's I love
my job because I have to get to have
these extraordinary experience right
some of which I'm qualified for in the
acting and some of which the athletic
things who is the toughest director you
ever had toughest because you've had
Soderbergh for Sex Lies and videotape
right Robert Altman for the player my
boy turtle Table four while you were
sleeping
Mike Nichols a couple of times nice and
Nichols a couple of times yeah my gosh
who pushed you the most or who brought
out Oh brought out the best well the
thing is the best directors don't have
to bring out the best in you because
they've already it's like what Altman
used to me is say I said Bob Buckley
never fire anybody I said why would I do
that
I said I you're here because I want you
to do what you do mm-hmm
the best you can do is surprise me huh
so that's what the best directors the
worst the most challenging directors
directors what I'm thinking in
particular who had determined before we
still went to work that it wasn't gonna
be something and so it made it hard to
to give him get past that because they
already had a preconceived notion of
what okay it was but I've been lucky
with the directors I've worked with mom
at the best and I'm glad to hear that
that John's doing a couple of these
episodes on NBC ghen xoe adore him he
said he is adored honor his well he is
and I'm not just saying that because my
wife and I love him and the fact that he
gave me my first movie break and
Disney's the kid that gives me a
residual check of a bottle not average
of four cents pretty much well those
four cent ones those are pretty damn
good pose you leave you scratching your
head at
Peter Gallagher on Twitter and again
check out Zoey's extraordinary playlist
on NBC at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central on
Sunday nights thanks for coming on
brother thanks rich you got it you think
right back at your we'll be up taking
your phone calls at eight four four two
Oh for rich to wrap up this Tuesday show
when we come back for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel - 39
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app